VR it's the future of gaming well maybe
we're almost a decade into the current
ERA of VR and outside of a couple
noteworthy bangers VR has still
struggled to be adapted by major
companies and franchises but you know
who does love VR Capcom or more
specifically their Resident Evil team
they have put out three soon to be four
major VR experiences for the iconic
horror franchise Resident Evil 7
biohazard for the PlayStation VR
Resident Evil 4 for the metaquest 2 and
Resident Evil Village for the
PlayStation VR2 so here's a question
are any of these actually worth playing
after all these aren't spin-offs or side
games but Mainline Resident Evil games
playable from start to finish in VR
that's kind of a big deal much like how
Half-Life Alex showed how VR can evolve
and elevate a beloved series I truly
believe the same as possible for
Resident Evil So today we're going to
explore how each of these games handles
VR what's great and not so great about
them and in one case provide an
alternate way to play Rise and Shine
sleepyhead it's time for supper out of
the entire Resident Evil catalog
Resident Evil 7 biohazard may be the
best design to take advantage of VR the
game is set in the intimate and
claustrophobic environment of the baker
estate with the actual explorable space
being tiny when compared to the grander
scope of other games as a result the
pace is rather slow encouraging you to
take your time in each room exploring
every nook and cranny and marveling and
all the disgusting detail
[Music]
yeah Resident Evil 7 goes for a hyper
realistic look and the baker Mansion
feels like a real place in how it's laid
out putting on a VR headset and being
transported to an alien world is cool
but being put into something closer to
reality is another thing entirely even
the game's off-maligned wrecked ship
section had me on the edge of my seat
thanks to how creepy it is in VR which
is why it's really unfortunate that
re7's VR mode is exclusive to psvr and
as a result is ultimately disappointing
and that's because these things
they kind of suck they have some pretty
severe limitations like no joysticks for
example so it's not a surprise that the
Resident Evil team doesn't even bother
using them instead opting to have the
player hold a dual shock 4 controller
the end result is that you don't quite
feel like you are protagonist Ethan
Winters but rather are controlling him
like you would in any other video game
only your head has now been transported
into virtual reality and also a gun has
been duct taped to it this actually
makes combat easier than playing
normally as all you have to do is look
at an enemy to lock directly onto their
head robbing a lot of attention the game
is full of ideas that feel tailored
designed for VR like holding your hands
up to block pouring Health on yourself
or even looking at your watch to see
your vitals but unfortunately these are
still left as button presses this all
feels poor compared to the good we're
eating with VR now and results in a lot
of the game's design and potential not
fully being taken advantage of so
unfortunately no re7s VR does not really
do much to change the way you play
Resident Evil but I do think it's
emphasis on horror makes it a worthwhile
game to experience in VR so real shame
that the Resident Evil 7 VR experience
is forever tied to this outdated and
obsolete piece of Hardware is what I
would say if we we didn't have the good
old PC modding Community God bless
that's right you can recreate The psvr
Experience on your PC and even bring
back some of its lost potential as long
as you're willing to put up with some
Jank that comes with this type of user
created experience all you need is a VR
headset compatible with steamvr in my
case I use the metaquest 2 with a Link
cable I'll provide a link in the
description of this video if you want to
try this yourself and honestly I found
the setup process to be fairly easy and
straightforward the greatest thing this
PC mod does is it Maps the controls to
touch style VR controllers meaning you
can now control Ethan's hands
independently and this isn't just for
show as it completely Alters the way
combat feels Gunplay is now frenetic and
messy relying on your own aim instead of
head shotting with your eyeballs and
guess what holding your hand up triggers
the block and you have to hold the
bottle upside down to poor health
medicine and if you look down at your
wrist you just see your health and it
all feels really natural finally these
features are reaching their full
potential granted because this is a fan
mod there are still a lot of limitations
you aren't going to be picking up
objects with your hands or interacting
with the environment I had a lot of
issues with button mapping to my
controls and I found weapon switching to
be really annoying the game also
defaults to having Ethan's body visible
instead of floating arms which I quickly
found to be distracting
thankfully there's a mod menu you can
open up and disable the body this does
unfortunately lead to some cut scene
weirdness like this one where Ethan gets
his ghost leg chopped off but that's the
kind of trade-off you're making with
this mod over the original the psvr may
be limited but it is a cleaner
experience but this is a really great
alternative and likely soon to be the
most accessible way to play Resident
Evil 7 in VR as the psvr itself is now a
discontinued product and the psvr 2
doesn't offer any backwards
compatibility
so that's cool so what if the developer
had more properly dedicated Dev time and
better VR Hardware to take advantage of
[Music]
foreign
before on the Quest 2 and it [__]
slaps everything missing in Resident
Evil 7 VR is here you got fully
autonomous hands direct interactivity
with objects like ammo and treasures the
guns all physically reload and feel so
good in short the VR implementation this
time around is great but what does this
actually do to the gameplay of re4 why
play this version well you are given so
much more to do thanks to the
integration of the touch controllers
things like dual wielding peeking open
doors holding a knife in one hand and a
gun in the other You're simply able to
express yourself more on how you play in
a way that is just not possible in
non-vr the game plays like a dream with
a large variety of options to tweak to
your liking and because it's on the
quest too it's really easy to pick up
and play anywhere you want no PC no
console no cables frankly I have so
little to say because it's just so good
if you like Resident Evil and you like
VR you should play this unless of course
you already own a non-quest 2 headset
and you don't want to buy another VR
headset because why would you do that
that's so much money and boy I really do
not like how once again this game is an
exclusive and yeah unfortunately there's
just no mod alternative for this one you
have to buy the headset
and speaking of having to buy a headset
where the hell am I
for as fantastic as resident before VR
is it didn't scratch the itch left
wanting from Resident Evil 7 because
they are two wildly different games with
very different combat goals Resident
Evil 4 is an action focused game all
about the combat and re7 is a horror
game that's more about the pacing and
the tension so while Resident Evil 4 VR
is a truly amazing experience from the
action side of the franchise
it didn't really do anything to satisfy
the slow paced horror I was looking for
I want something that can truly capture
that side of Resident Evil in VR which
is why I was excited for Village because
on paper it should provide the Resident
Evil VR experience I've been waiting for
it's not like it's not bad but it's got
a lot of glaring issues that gets in its
way but first I do want to highlight
that there is some really cool stuff in
here and I want to give credit where
credit is due the flexibility of
handling the weapons is just as great as
it was in Resident Evil 4. and hey you
could even throw the knife now you can
also open up Ethan's coat which you can
map items to such as landmines there's
even a physical flashlight you can hold
in addition I love because it ramps up
the tension forcing you to use only
one-handed weapons when in a dark
claustrophobic environment the map is
also something you have to hold straight
out of Far Cry 2 which I completely
adore however these additions also have
their issues or just don't feel as
meaningful as they could be for example
the flashlight becomes a lot less cool
once you realize it will automatically
turn on anyways and you don't actually
need to pull it out or take the
reliability of opening up Ethan's jacket
it can be clumsy and not ideal In the
Heat of battle also it just doesn't work
the way you think it would sometimes
like here's me trying to take out and
throw a mine on the ground turns out you
need to press it and it just drops to
the ground it's just a weird holdover
from how it works in the non-vr version
and then there's Ethan's body it's
physically present the whole time
instead of just being a pair of floating
hands and I find this experience less
enjoyable as a result you may think
seeing his arms would be more realistic
but instead you just kind of feel
disconnected once you notice they don't
always match up with your own arms and
the body really gets in the way during
cut scenes where Ethan moves on his own
in Village most of the cutscenes are
played in real time rather than a video
that plays on a screen like in seven and
four and originally I thought I would
prefer this because it doesn't break the
illusion but this ends up also breaking
it only in different ways like having
your body disconnect from your head as
it keeps walking or having Ethan wake up
lying on the ground but you are still
very much standing up straight in your
own living room and the whole thing
feels very silly
however there are moments where it all
comes together beautifully once you get
to Castle demotrascu the VR starts to
shine more because the game lets you
play around more and the castle is
beautiful in VR like God damn and of
course there's house benevento that [__]
is still [__] awful and horrifying
and I really wish I could have
experienced that for the first time in
VR I realize some of this might sound in
picky and I'll admit a lot of the VR
features in this game are cool additions
and leagues better than what we got in
seven but forests at the bar really high
and at the end of the day a lot of
villages design gets in the way I should
also mention that the PC VR mod for re7
also works with Village so if you want
you can play this on PC however it is a
very limited VR experience in the same
way that these seven mod is and in this
case the lack of polish on the touch
controls weapon handling and lack of
additional features like the flashlight
make it a downgrade when compared to the
psvr 2 version if you want the best
possible VR experience you got to play
it on PlayStation
which once again brings us to the
biggest problems surrounding all three
of these games it is an exclusive
lockdown to only one VR headset yes it
is technically a very nice headset and
for VR it's actually a pretty good deal
but it is still way too expensive for
most people to justify it's unfortunate
that price and exclusivity complicate
and ultimately dictate the conversation
when originally all we wanted to know
a Resident Evil and the answer is yeah
they totally are Resident Evil 4
no-brainer it's the winner so to speak
Village meanwhile ends up feeling the
most ambitious but ends up being jankier
because it still has to work within the
restrictive limitations that arise from
a game not being created with VR in the
first place I think the reason why re4
ends up being the stronger of the two is
thanks to the game's more simple
presentation translating better to VR
it's also a standalone product and
certainly got more development time and
money put into it than Villages VR mode
which was created almost two years after
release and even though its VR
implementation is the weakest I found
re7 as a game to be a better fit for VR
simply because it's genre and design
lend to the atmospheric aspects that VR
is so good at amplifying the intense
dread of the baker State feels more real
than any of the locations and Village
and for and makes the whole illusion
work more effectively this leaves me
very curious about the upcoming Resident
Evil 4 remake VR mode the VR for the
original Resident Evil 4 is damn near
perfect and if they copy that instead of
how they handle Village I think this
could be their best attempt at VR yet
but personally I'd really love to see
what a full-blown VR only Resident Evil
game could truly be one that is more in
the vein of survival horror than
Survival action imagine if you will a
remake of Resident Evil 1 exclusively
for VR and how freaking cool that would
be I'm talking about having a bend over
in Dallas zombies and oil and light it
on fire so it doesn't come back
interactive puzzles like needing to push
crates to block doors and of course you
have to play Moonlight Sonata on the
piano
so cool it's not gonna happen
or will it come on Capcom
come on Capcom
come on
you know you want to
[Music]